th Ardisson on va parler de TI Ardisson
je sais pas ce qu'il a mon Thierry là
ces derniers temps là qui connaît
thardisson déjà tout le monde tout le
monde connait ti Ardisson bon c'est un
animateur télé télé je sais pas ce qu'il
a il arrête pas de de de défoncer tout
le monde en ce moment il est colère je
sais pas on dirait qu' sais on dirait
les gars là dans la rue qui t'insultent
quand tu passes tout ça je sais pas ce
qu'il a bon je pas envoyé de texto pas
voulu et il a voulu nous tacler et il a
taclé mundir qui s'est pris une balle
perdue au passage mon ami mundir et je
vais répondre à tir Radisson parce que
je j'adore mundir en fait et j'ai pas
aimé qu' qui s'en prenne à à mundir qui
est vraiment devenu un très bon pote et
qui est UNAR quelqu'un de de très
sensible mundir c'est un garçon qui est
vraiment d'une en qui j'ai une entière
confiance et qui a un amour de mec et
qui ne se permet jamais de juger les
autres ou de dire du mal des autres et
tiardisson le donneur de leçon s'est
permis de donner une une leçon
d'histoire à mundir mundir il peut faire
faire des erreurs parfois des trucs mais
on s'en fout on l'aime comme ça nous ce
qui compte c'est pas le savoir c'est le
cœur et peut-être que thardardisson a
plus de savoir que mundir mais il a
beaucoup moins de cœur et beaucoup plus
d'aigreur donc regardez ce qu'il a dit
il disent rien de transgressif Anouna il
dit rien de transgressif il dit que des
conneries je dire c'est pas pareil de
dire des choses transgressives de de
d'essayer de faire avancer les idées et
cetera puis de de de faire ce qu' fait t
mais c'est pas consensuel moi quand je
vois mundir qui nous explique que déjà
on avait eu on a eu Alexandra subli qui
nous explique qui savait pas quelle
année avait commencé la guerre de 40 sur
la sur la 5 qui était quand même la
chaîne de la culture et de la
connaissance vous n'z pas changé après
non mais après là j'ai vu mundir nous
expliquer que c'est grâce au aux Arabes
qu'on a gagné la guerre de 40 je veux
dire vous l'avez vu ça non mais comment
je veux bien que Vincent boloret veuille
être encore plus milliardaire que ce
qu'il est milliardaire mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut laisser sur sa chaîne
qui lui appartient dire des conneries
pareilles moi je connais Vincent boloret
je comprends pas qu'il laisse dire des
choses comme ça connais tellement bien
Vincent
Boloré qu'on a voilà qui qu'il est parti
un tirardisson malheureusementil de de
la chaîne tirardisson non non mais non
mais tirardisson il a une aigreur parce
que je vais vous raconter voulait rester
sur la chaîne son émission coûtait
extrêmement cher sachez-le c'était
vraiment pour vous dire c'était le
double de TPMP pour la moitié d'audience
donc forcément à un moment bon quand
vous avez un mec qui coûte très cher et
qui produit une émission et qui avec une
deux fauteuils et un bureau et trois
personnes dans le public et que
l'émission est facturée deux fois plus
que l'émission phare de la chaîne qui
fait deux fois plus d'audience à un
moment ça ça coince et je vais vous
raconter l'histoire puisque
thisson il aime bien parler donc je vais
parler de lui tiardisson je vais vous
expliquer c'était un on avait trouvé un
terrain d'entente voilà avec lui et
tierardisson il me dit oui c'est tout ça
c'est très bien ok on y va on est
reparti une heure après on voit ti
rardisson qui fait une Inter V dans Le
Parisien pour dire je finalement non
donc il est incroyable ce gars donc
voilà donc on lui avait dit de de revoir
un petit peu à la baisse c'estes ses ses
prétentionsadon parce que forcément je
vous dis l'émission coûtait extrêmement
cher et on voit pas comment il arrivait
à un chiffre pareil à part si c'était
pour s'acheter des costumes donc le
problème voilà donc a un moment
tiradisson il faut qu'il vive avec son
temps aussi avec la télé d'aujourd'hui
ti rardisson il peut pas faire des
émissions hyper chèes pour si peu
d'audience alors peut-être que France
Télévision avec votre argent peut lui
donner de l'argent pour faire son hôtel
du temps qui é déplacé d'ailleurs de
20h50 maintenant à 22h30 donc déjà que
c'était pas regarder bah là les
personnes décédées qui qui l'interview
ben seront encore plus mortes puisquil
vont passer encore plus tard donc
thierardisson malheureusement encore une
fois Thierry tu sais moi je pense que un
animateur et j'espère que j'aurai le la
lucidité de le faire quand tu n'es plus
tu sens plus les choses quand tu n'es
plus dans le coup il faut arrêter il
faut aller planter des poireaux dans son
jardin et faire un potager et être
tranquillement en train d'aller cueillir
les légumes le matin dans son jardin au
lieu de venir parasiter la télé de ceux
qui la font et toi tu ne l'as fais plus
Thierry malheureusement tu ne fais que
la commenter ça devient pitoyable non
mais c'est vrai Thierry donc c'est tu
fais de la peine à tout le monde voilà
on t'aimait bien tu as fait des grandes
choses tu es un grand animateur un grand
producteur et là tu te fais du mal voilà
donc on voilà on a rien j'ai limite rien
contre toi mon Thierry mais arrête voilà
regardez Vendel il l'a défoncé Ruquier
tiens regarde il avait t clé Ruquier
aussi ti on va voir regardez ti ben tu
nous diras ce que tu en penses
regardez ça pas marché parce que Laurent
était pas du tout dans l'émission c'està
dire c'est de la faute de Laurent ah bah
oui là carrément là celu là pour le coup
tous les gens qui étaient sur le plateau
vous pourraz vous le raconter c'est pas
mon avis la promesse n'était pas tenue
non il a je crois qu'il est pas rentré
il fait beaucoup de choses Laurent il
était un peu peut-être surmené en tous
les cas il est pas rentré du tout dans
l'émission c'était pas du tout ce qu'on
attendait en tous les cas du cé le fait
que la chaîne ait arrêté l'émission je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose Thierry
c'est pas que Laurent n'était pas dans
l'émission il a produit laqu sur un
prime time thardisson Thierry tout le
monde le sait dans le métier tu n'es ni
fait pour l'access semaine ni fait pour
les primetime tu n'as jamais réussi en
primetime Thierry toi-même en tant
qu'animateur Laurent quand il fait des
primes il a cartonné plein Laurent pour
le coup c'est un animateur de prime il a
fait de nombreux cartons prime ce qui
n'est pas ton cas Thierry donc il avait
certainement des bons producteurs qu'il
produisait bien en prime toi tu ne sais
ni produire en prime time ni présenter
en prime time donc n met pas la faute
sur Laurent Ruquet qui a eu de nombreux
succès en prime time c'est pas possible
ça non pas toi thier pas toi ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que il a supplié
presque à genoux Laurent pour produire
ce programme c'est lui qui a fait des
pieds et des mains pour faire cette
émission il a été bien bien évidemment à
ce moment-là d'une gentillesse absolue
parce que c'est un volte face permanent
C pendant des années moi c'est ça il
fait semblant d'être d'être l'ami le bon
ami quand ça l'arrange quand il a des
choses à à récupérer et puis en fait
après il vous met des coups de couteaux
dans le dos pour moi c'est le le le le
pire pour moi pour moi c'est être une
pourriture je pèse mes mots mais ce
genre de comportement mettre un coup de
poignard dans le dos de ses de ses amis
du métier qu' qu'on à qui on a fait de
la lèche quelques temps après pour dire
tout lui remettre sur le dos alors que
c'est parce que c'était mal produit mais
excusez Mo c'est pas un comportementne
je texplique moi pendant des années mon
cul c'était une peau de chamoi tellement
il a lustré hein mais je te dis oui je
vais le dire mais je te le dis et et moi
il et moi il m'arrivé je vais raconter
une anecdote avec tion qui est
incroyableelle est incroyable cette
anecdote parce que tu te rappelles que
j'étais en embrouille avec Laurent r un
moment j'étais en embrouille avec
Laurent Laurent et moi parce que on
était en face à la télé à la radio et
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
déclarations qu'on faisait chacun de
notre côté et c'est vrai que voilà on se
chauffait un petit peu et un jour il
fait un prime time tien Ardisson où il y
a Laurent et j'avais dit avant j'avais
dit non je veux pas être avec Laurent
sur le même plateau et Laurent avait dit
je veux pas être avec cyil sur le même
plateau en ce moment c'est chaud et
d'ailleurs après on a une discussion
avec Laurent on a décidé de se voir tous
les deux et depuis tu peux le confirmer
Hugo on s'entend vraiment très bien et
Laurent c'est ça que j'ai aimé avec lui
c'est qu'il a pris son téléphone il m'a
dit Cyril viens on se voit je trouve que
c'est pas bien qu'on voilà qu'on se
prenne la tête comme ça en plus on s'en
sentendrait très bien on a pris un verre
ensemble et depuis ça c'était il y a 5 6
ans et depuis Laurent et moi on est et
je le défends toujours parce que je
maintenant je le considère comme un ami
et il le sait je le défends toujours et
voilà oui parce que vous avez une valeur
commune c'est que vous êtes droit et
vous êtes fidèle et que voilà vous ne
déviez pas de route en fonction de là où
le vent va et Laurent quand il te dit un
truc il le fait voilà quand il te dit
c'est pas voilà donc ti radon quand il
te dit un truc il va faire le contraire
5 minutes après bon et donc il y a
Laurent Ruquet sur le plateau et je suis
en loge et je vois j'ai le retour il le
sait pas j'ai le retour ils sont pas en
train de tourner mais je le retourne
dans ma loge et donc je vois tir un
Ardisson qui dit il y a son attach qui
dit oui mais il faut faire sortir
Laurent parce qu'il y a cyil adouna qui
va venir on avait dit à Cyril que et à
Laurent que ilsétaient pas ensemble sur
le plateau et là je vois tir rardisson
qui dit qu'est-ce qu'il va me faire
chier ce Hanouna il va se faire [__]
il sera avec Laurent rquier et puis il
ferme sa
gueule j'ai dit fais-moi monter Thierry
dans ma loge j'ai d faismi donc là j'ai
fermé la loge je su arrivé je vais
parler
gentiment il m'a dit mais non mais j'ai
jamais dit ça donc il me dit à moi j'ai
jamais dit ça il me ment à moi alors que
je viens de le voir et c'est tout
tiardisson ça veut dire c'est pas de
face c'est incroyable non mais c'est fou
du talent il a du talent tiens ça on
peut pas lui enlever il a du talent il a
une vision c'est un très bon animateur
de deuxèe partie de soirée pour moi
c'est peut-être le meilleur animateur de
deè partie de soirée peut-être un des
seuls en France parce que tout le monde
a essayé les deiè parties de soiré avec
Laurent je pense ETA aujourd'hui qui qui
qui le fait bien aussi Léa Laurent et
voilà mais
sinon Thierry Le problème c'est que il
est pas fiable voilà oui je peux le
défendre oui parce que là vous racontez
l'envers du décor mais les gens qui
regardent la télé aujourd'hui c'est plus
un homme de la télé donc il a le droit
lui en tant que spectateur et qui
regarde la télé de dire ce qu'il aime et
ce qu'il aime pas et de la même manière
il a le droit de dire qu'il aime PASP on
a pas un tot
d'imunité ta on taille tous les
programmes où on dire on a une li j'ai
pas aimé j'ai pas aimé j'ai pas c'est
pas ça il mait té moi j'ai programme
c'est genre un peu m c'est un abouti
te dis moi je suis désolé Mo c'est un
mec que j'adore et c'est un mec qui qui
qui qui a fait
déjà je vous le dis M il est parti de
rien et déjà ce qu'il a fait c'est
exceptionnel et c'est un mec que j'aime
moi parce que c'est un mec je sais que
c'est un mec fiable et voilà c'est un
mec que j'aime énormément et c'est un
mec je sais que si j'ai une galère à 4h
du matin j'appelle mundir et ben il sera
là et moi je préfère un mec comme ça qui
a du cœur plutôt qu'un mec qui a du
savoir surtouton n'a jamais fait direct
contrairement à nous parce que c'est un
homme re sa vie çaé l'reistr alors il
avait taclé aussi alexandreé pendant des
années cé il avait dit il est très con
Fogel Marco Olivier Fogel aussi il avait
fracassé Marc Olivier Fogel alors que
qu'on aime Marc Olivier Fogel ou pas je
suis désolé il a énormément de talent
voilà voilà
Marco il les producteurs pierreantoine
cAPTON voilà donc il fracasse tout le
mondeandé moi je trouve qu'elle a un
talent aussi j'adore Aland sublé elle a
un truc voilà donc ou il a raison de
donner son avis comme dit Géraldine en
tant que recul en tant commomme de la
grand homme de la télé moi je regardais
tout le monde en parle j'étais j'étais
fan et là où je rejoins Géraldine c'est
que nous c'est du direct ici alors
évidemment il dit on n'est pas à
tranessif c'est pas ce qu'il a dit mais
mundir lui il parle avec son cœur alors
peut-être qu'il a dit il a dit une
bêtise ce soir-là mais au moment il l'a
dit en direct avec son cœur c'était pas
un truc préparé Alexandra subl c'est
pareil elle est en direct c'est des
émissions qui sont faites en direct tous
les gens qui taclent bah c'est des gens
qui font de la radio en direct Laurent
Ruquier il est capable de faire de la
radio en direct moi j'ai j'ai fait un
tout petit peu de radio je peux vous
dire que la radio en direct pendant des
heures c'est pas donné à tout le monde
il faut savoir le faire ouais mais non
mais d'accord
mais non moi j'ai pas d'info je donne
mon ressenti en tant enant en tant que
téléspectateur je pense que de tacler
mundir et Tac PMP c'est pas c'est pas
une
bonne étient très copains vous é ils
étaient très copainson il il y avait une
sorte de de respect et après oui oui
relativement pote il est déjà allé chez
che chez Thierry Ardisson donc oui ils
avaient quand même un bon relationnel
mais c'est d'autant plus surprenant que
que que d'avoir un tel comportement avec
quelqu'un qu'on a soit-disant apprécié
il y a un moment où un peu de fidélité
un peu de valeur un peu de voilà le
métier ça n'excuse pas tout et quand tu
parles du fait que en effet il a le
droit de d'être téléspectateur et puis
de de juger les choses on peut le faire
avec un peu de classe voilà ouais pro et
puis le faire avec un peu de respect
pour l'être humain qui en
de on ne peut pas juger les G moi je
suis sû il a eu de la peine quand
il
Pascal d'ailleurs quand il vous vous a
viré heureusement qu'il m'a viré
j'aurais jamais pu assumer la dérive
idéologique de C absolument absolument
parce que si qu'est-ce que je ferais
aujourd'hui si je faisais saluléérien je
Seris obligé de faire comme Pascal pro
dire que je vais à la messe le dimanche
pour me faire bien voir de mon patron
bah peut-être que c'est vrai tout
simplement qui va à la messe le dimanche
oui enfin c'était quand même le titre
dans le Journal du Dimanche donc Pascal
pro en direct non mais Thierry tu sais
Pascal Pro a beaucoup plus de liberté
que toi et je te le dis et il fait des
émissions beaucoup plus subversives que
toi je suis désolé excuse-moi qu'on
l'aime ou pas excuse-moi de te dire ça
Thierry Thierry toi je je sais pas où
tuas à part toi toi tu étais subversif
dans le truc c'est quoi c'est dans parce
que tu as dit est-ce que su sais s'est
trompé mais tu as jamais fait un truc
politique ou une idéologie que tu as
essayé de porter ou tu as donné ton avis
sur quelque chose tu te planquais
derrière tes invités tu as piégé de
nombreux invités d'ailleurs par tes
montages fallacieux derrière que tu
faisais et tu mettais à chaque fois tes
invité il disait que tu les mettais dans
une sauce terrible donc voilà Pascal pro
je pense que Pascal pro quand il dit
qu'il va à la messe le dimanche je pense
que c'est vrai contrairement à toi quand
tu dis que tu es un mec bien donc voilà
donc écoute moi je préfère les mecs qui
disent la vérité plutôt qu'un mec qui
passe son temps à cracher sur les autres
et qui surtout n'est pas fiable voilà il
a c'est zéro fiabilité ce mec voilà moi
c'est vrai que je peux parler je peux
cracher sur les gens mais quand j'ai des
potes je défends toujours mes potes
voilà lui Laurent c'était son pote il
m'a craché dessus on était nous aussi
assez proche quand il était sur C8
derrière il il il nous fracasse voilà et
en fait il tourne demain je vous
explique si demain Alexandra sublé va
voir tir Ardisson il lui dit j'aimerais
bien que tu me produises il va dire que
c'est la meilleure animatrice du monde
et qu'elle est formidable voilà donc
tierardardisson il pense qu' a une chose
c'est essayer d'être riche euh il a très
bien gagné sa vie mais il a un problème
parce qu'il je pense aussi qu'il a une
certaine il est il est un peu frustré
parce que il aurait aimé être plus riche
plus successful tirardisson voilà et
voilà il a il est bien mais c'est pas
Laurent ruier voilà malheureusement
c'est pas la carrière de Laurent rier
c'est pas mine de rien la réussite de
Laurent rier donc forcément il a un
petit peu même de la réussite faut être
quelqu'un de bien dans la vie c'est
important d'être quelqu'un de bien peu
importe ce qu'on fait comme métier c'est
pas quelqu'un de bien
ah oui vous êtes non c'est pas quelqu'un
de bien je suis désolé à travers tout ce
qu'il fait depuis des années toutes les
critiques qu'il fait aux personnes qui
lu ont tendu la main pour moi c'est une
preuve vraiment de de d'un manque de
valeur humaine enfin c'est c'est c'est
pour moi ça être une saloperie et juste
pour revenir sur Pascal pro Pascal pro
qu'on l'aime ou pas il arrive il est en
direct c'est ça le truc la journée c'est
pas tir Ardisson qui prépare ses
émissions avec 50 répétitions et 46
fiches et qui lit mot à mot ce que lui
ont écrit c'estes 15 auteurs parce que
c'était la mission pourquoielle coûtait
cher par qu'il avait 15 auteurs parce
que même pour poser une question il a
besoin de 15 auteurs il sit pas écrire
une question qui découpe en fonction de
qui voilà non mais bon pour montages
c'est c'était fallacieux parfois he